la elección de nayib mikati como no
primer ministro puede dar una imagen de
cierta estabilidad muy necesaria de cara
a conferencia internacional de donantes
para el líbano que se celebrará el día 4
coincidiendo con el aniversario de la
explosión del puerto de virus sin
embargo que mikati pueda formar gobierno
se presenta como una tarea difícil su
antecesor saad hariri después de nueve
meses de intentarlo dimitió la semana
pasada mikati representa a la vieja
guardia a esa élite política de los
manifestantes de las protestas de 2019
quería derrocar ha sido dos veces primer
ministro y tiene una larga lista de
casos de corrupción por los que nunca ha
sido procesado el líbano lleva
prácticamente un año sin gobierno y ha
recibido una gran presión por parte de
francia la iniciativa del presidente
manuel macro es la formación de un
gobierno que dé garantías y que ponga en
marcha las reformas políticas y
económicas tan necesarias para rescatar
al país del colapso total el líbano se
encuentra en una espiral de crisis
económica política sin gasolina
prácticamente con la moneda en caída
libre